Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, ladies and
gents. This is Tim Feriss. Welcome to another
episode of The Tim Feriss Show, and it is my
pleasure today to have Willoughby Britton,
PhD on the podcast. She is a clinical
psychologist, and associate professor
of psychiatry and human behavior at Brown
University Medical School, and the director
of Brown's Clinical and Affective Neuroscience
Laboratory, and that is affective with an A. Her
clinical and neuroscience research investigates
the effects of contemplative practices, i.e.,
meditation, or certainly one example being
meditation on the brain and body in the treatment
of mood disorders, trauma, and other conditions.
She's especially interested in which practices are
best or worst suited for which types of people, or
conditions, and why. She's probably best known for
her research on adverse effects, why they happen,
and how to mitigate them, and we'll be doing a
very deep dive on this, certainly. Dr. Britton is
the founder of Cheetah House, as in the large and
very fast cat, Cheetah House, a nonprofit
organization that provides evidence-based
information, and support for meditators
in distress, as well as meditation safety
trainings to providers, and organizations. You can
find Cheetah House on Twitter @CheetahHouseOrg.
Facebook, you can find @cheetahhouse.org, and on
Instagram, @cheetah.house. Dr. Britton, thank you
for making the time today. Nice to see you.
Willoughby Britton: Thank
you so much for having me.
Tim Ferriss: There are many reasons that I wanted
to have a conversation with you, and one certainly
was due to my own experience at a silent retreat,
and having a flooding of traumatic memories, and
everything that that led to it was overwhelming,
to an extent that I could not have imagined, and
certainly had not been prepared for. Secondly is
a mutual acquaintance, I won't mention his name,
because he's one of the more private people in
the world, so I would always want to double-check.
Had suggested that we talk, because there might be
some mapping, or some similarities at least
between meditation-related adverse events,
and how symptoms present some of the dissociation,
et cetera, that you can observe in some people,
and some of the adverse effects that you can see,
some persistent effects after psychedelic use.
So, eventually, we'll get to that.
But let's start at the beginning,
or at least with the genesis story of sorts. How
did you first become interested in meditation?
Willoughby Britton: So I think, like many people,
I had a life crisis that precipitated the need
for something really different in my life. One of
my childhood friends committed suicide when I was
in college, the summer between my junior
and senior year. And it was devastating,
and completely dysregulating to see a
person just disappear from the world.
It wasn't in my repertoire of possibilities
that somebody could just not be there anymore,
so I needed some — so, I had probably diagnosable
PTSD at that point, and I really didn't want to
take medication. I was only 20. And my dad
sent me A Path with Heart by Jack Kornfield,
and that became my Bible for the next, probably,
decade, and so for those of you who don't know,
Jack Kornfield is a very famous meditation
teacher, and he's written many books. In this
particular one, like many of them start off with
just what the mind can do, and how to work with
it, and it just is very practical, a practical way
to manage all of the emotions that were happening.
And it was great, because it was allowing them
to be there too, it wasn't suppressing them.
Ironically, that book, that particular book that
he wrote, I only got about halfway through it,
because the whole second half I just could not
relate to, because it was like the spiritual
roller coaster, and like Kundalini awakenings.
And I was like, "I don't know what that is, so
I'll just put that down. Just take what you need,
whatever." And then that came back. Fast-forward
15 years, I was like, "Oh, right. That second
half of that book, let me go back and read that."
But I'm getting ahead of myself. So, going
into graduate school, I was also very,
very interested in consciousness always, and
always interested in just, what are we doing
here? What's going on? And what's looking out of
my eyes, and just very curious. And so, that was
already happening. And then I had this experience
and it culminated in my graduate career looking
at altered states of consciousness in a clinical
psychology program at the University of Arizona,
which happens to be, at the time, the only place
in the world that had a consciousness study
center. So, I was doing that and actually,
my professional life, I actually studied
near-death experiences for my master's thesis.
And my own personal trauma, and meditation
practice was something I was doing on my personal
time. It was not part of my scholarship. But I
think at some point during graduate school, those
two lives were so divided that I needed to combine
them just to be like an integrated human being.
And so for my dissertation, I did a study on the
effects of mindfulness training on sleep, and the
reason — I was working in a sleep lab, and sleep
is, it's a legal altered state of consciousness,
and it's linked with every type of possible
health issue. And so, if you want to study altered
states of consciousness, it's a good one to study,
because it's, you're not going to have — it's
not like psychedelics that get banned. Everyone
does it. It happens every day.
Tim Ferriss: Hard to ban sleep.
Willoughby Britton: So it was a good one to
choose. And at the time, this is around 2000,
there really wasn't great research.
A lot of the meditation research was
on self-reports. There wasn't a lot of brain
data available, and so I was going to be one
of the first people to record overnight sleep
polysomnography, so this is brain-based sleep,
and prove that meditation was improving
sleep because, of course, it was. I mean,
it's relaxing, et cetera. So, that was my
dissertation, and I spent like 200 nights
watching people sleep. And at the end of the
day, the hypothesis was not at all what I
expected. So we actually found that no matter
how you measured arousal, cortical arousal,
brain arousal, meditation was associated with
increasing it, not decreasing it, so it was
causing insomnia in people. And we looked at
percentage of slow-wave sleep that went down.
We went, and looked at how fast the brainwaves
were. Those went up, and the correlation was,
with the amount of practice was 0.8. So no matter
where you went, there it was, and this is my
first confession is that I didn't publish the
data. I was like an evangelist for meditation,
because this is something that had really helped
me, and I really wanted to use my science,
and my position as a scientist to promote
this thing, and so I didn't publish the data.
At some point, when I came to Brown to
do my residency, a couple of years later,
I was on a meditation retreat, and I
mentioned the data that I had found,
which is basically that it was causing cortical
arousal, and insomnia. And the meditation teacher
sort of chastised me and said, "I don't know why
all you clinical psychologists are always trying
to make meditation into a relaxation technique.
Everyone knows that if you meditate enough,
you stop sleeping." And I was like, "What?"
Tim Ferriss: Bulletin!
Willoughby Britton: Yeah. And so that was
like a wake-up call, literally. And I thought,
"Okay. Well, what other assumptions are we
making?" I was definitely pretty emblematic of
a lot of people who go into meditation research,
or the average meditator, which is like, I didn't
really know my Buddhism, I didn't really know my
history. I just signed up for whatever was around,
and believed everything that people said, and the
way that it was marketed as a health promotion
tonic. I believed all that, and I didn't do
my homework, which is pretty terrible as a
meditation researcher. And so I was like, "Okay.
It looks like I need to do some history homework,
and really look at the background of what kinds
of assumptions we're making as health providers,
and really look at the translation process
of how these practices, where they came from,
what kinds of changes they made, what
was the journey like to get here into
the West, and really unpack that process."
And then the second question was, "Well, what
other little nuggets of knowledge do these
meditation teachers have that they're not telling
us?" And there's a follow-on part of the story,
which is when I came to Brown to do my clinical
residency, you have to do a year of internship
to see clients, basically to get your license.
I worked at an inpatient psychiatric hospital,
and during that one year, there were two yogis
who came off retreat, completely psychotic. And
I thought like, "Wow, two in one year is, it's a
lot." It seemed like a lot to me. So I went back
to the same teacher and I said, "Well, have you
ever seen this before?" And I remember distinctly
that there was no actual verbal reaction,
but there was this look of like, "Oh, shit."
And I was like, "Oh, oh, wow. There is a story
here. There is a knowledge that this can happen,
and meditation teachers are sitting on this,
just a ton of information that needs to be mined."
And as a meditation researcher, I was like, "Okay,
we need to start asking these questions." So that
whole story is the beginning of the Varieties
of Contemplative Experience study, which was
probably the simplest study that I've ever done,
the hardest, but simplest. And that it was
basically just going to meditation centers,
and teachers, and saying, "What types of
challenges have you observed in your students?
How do you make sense of them? What are they? How
do you interpret them? And then very practically,
what do you do about them?" Very straightforward
set of questions, and that took 10 years. It's
3,000 pages of qualitative data, and I don't even
know how many papers we've written. We're still
writing papers based on that data. I think we're
at over 10 now, so it's really just a wormhole,
which we're going to go down together.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, we are going to go arm-in-arm
down the wormhole. So let me pause for a second.
I want to make a promise to folks, and I'll give
you a heads-up also, we will come back to the
near-death experiences. I'm going to leave that as
a Scooby Snack at the end for people, so I do want
to talk about that. However, I want to dig into
the sleep for one second, because if people stop
sleeping, period, full stop, eventually they die,
right? So the restorative functions of sleep, as
it is still poorly understood, but are critical to
human functioning, and survival. How would you
explain, if it is indeed true, that if people
meditate enough, they stop sleeping, or they
start sleeping very minimally? How would you
explain that? Is it that the meditation practice
itself provokes a state that is restorative,
and therefore the sleep is less necessary,
or is there something else that you would
put as the front-runner for explaining that?
Willoughby Britton: We can point readers to
various papers. There is a paper that was called
"Awakening Is Not a Metaphor." I had to fight
hard to keep that title.
Tim Ferriss: That's
pretty good. That's pretty good.
Willoughby Britton: Yeah. But it's
a review of different studies across different
types of methodologies, looking at how meditation
affects the wake-sleep system, and it's not
as straightforward as you stop sleeping,
or you sleep less. It's going to be dependent on
many factors. And I will say that in the study
that I was just talking about, my dissertation
study, we found a non-monotonic, non-linear
relationship. So if people who are meditating
less than half an hour, and less than every day,
they actually had an increase in sleep quality.
But people who are meditating more than that,
that's when it sort of switched and turned
into, they were prone to being more awake,
more insomnia, and more cortical arousal, so
it's sort of biphasic, nonlinear relationship.
So, just to recap, it's not going
to give you insomnia, probably,
Tim Ferriss: Automatically, yes. Because
when we talk about meditation, it's like,
"Oh, you do meditation?" It's kind of like,
"Oh, you do sports," or, "You do exercise."
Willoughby Britton: Right.
Tim Ferriss: It's like, well, there are a million
different parameters, and types, and so on.
Willoughby Britton: Right. And I think one of
the other papers that I wrote, which is called,
"Can Mindfulness Be Too Much of a Good Thing?"
Introduces this idea of that there's, at a small
amount, or an optimal amount can do exactly what
the hype, and the promotions, and the advertising
says. There is a lot of truth in the advertising,
and the positive reports. But there's another
side of the story which often comes with sort of
higher doses. So, one of the ways to understand
this particular finding, and actually a lot
of the other ones that are on the hyperarousal
spectrum would be, if you think about meditation
as a attention-enhancing product, it gets often
compared with, or marketed alongside Ritalin,
and Modafinil, and coffee, and caffeine, and all
these stimulants that help attention. And so,
if you think about meditation as one of those,
I mean, think about what happens when you —
Tim Ferriss: Spiritual Modafinil,
which is an anti-narcolepsy drug
for people who don't recognize it.
Willoughby Britton: Yeah. If you think
about any of the consequences, and many of
us have personal experience with a lot of
these substances, taking too many of them,
taking too much. Just drink too much coffee,
what happens? You have a panic attack, and you
can't sleep. You take amphetamines, or cocaine,
or whatever the stimulant is, you take enough of
it, and it's going to be on the fear spectrum.
And some of them, if you take enough of it, it's
going to be on the psychosis spectrum, especially
if you have tendencies in that direction. So,
it doesn't seem like a huge leap to think that
here's another attention-enhancing product that,
with certain people and certain types of doses,
it's going to lead to a hyperarousal syndrome, and
that's pretty much exactly what we're seeing. So,
that is one of the potential mechanisms.
Tim Ferriss: So, what I might do for folks who
just don't have the personal context on me that I
alluded to earlier is, I'll tell if it's okay with
you, a bit of my story, which in some ways led to
this conversation, and certainly, it sounds like,
based on what we were discussing before recording,
that people have mentioned this to you. So,
it's been a match made for many reasons, so I
want to give folks sort of a contrast by giving
present day, and then the story of what happened
to me at my silent retreat, which was a Vipassana
retreat. So if we look at, for instance, the
last two weeks, I have meditated twice a day,
20 minutes a day, very straightforward
transcendental meditation. And there's lots of
wacky weird stuff if you go deep enough and weird
enough with TM. But if you're taking it for the
off-the-shelf offering, and following the basic
guidelines, I find it incredibly therapeutic.
And I find also, difficult to disambiguate. I
haven't had any caffeine whatsoever in two weeks,
so the combination of those two, for, I suppose,
a lot of sensible reasons, seems to really help.
I've been getting some of the best sleep in the
last 10 years, probably, in the last one or two
weeks. I'm sure, the abstinence from coffee, and
caffeine, no small part of that. And I've seen no
adverse events whatsoever, and I've done a lot of
TM over the years, and other types of meditation.
But TM, I find to be the easiest life raft of
sorts. However, if we flash back, and this sort
of alludes to the, maybe like the Paracelsus, the
dose makes the poison, I approached my meditation
retreat, and this was at Spirit Rock, which is a
beautiful, beautiful facility, beautiful campus,
really run by excellent people, and ended up
being very fortunate that the author of the
book you mentioned, A Path with Heart,
that Jack Kornfield was at Spirit Rock.
He ended up being the person who effectively
triaged, and helped address the situation I
found myself in, ultimately. But I approached
the silent retreat with the wrong mindset,
and the wrong set of expectations. I thought
to myself, I've done lots of meditation. If
you add up all the time that I've meditated,
it's quite a bit. I've spent time by myself,
and I've also done A, B, C, D, and E, really
not recognizing that they're two different,
for me at least, and for many people, two
different species of experience. And since
I had heard that it was the last time Jack would
be leading a retreat, I'm not sure if that ended
up being the case or not, I decided that I wanted
to get absolutely as much out of it as possible.
I'd seen benefits from fasting before, I'd seen
benefits from lower doses of psychedelics before.
So I thought to myself, this is probably
aggressive, but why don't I combine all three?
And that ended up being incredibly problematic,
but not immediately. I'd done the fasting. So
I fasted going into this week-long retreat, and
then after a few days of establishing my baseline,
let's call it three days, I started adding
increasing doses, daily, of blended, homogenized,
dried psilocybe mushrooms, so people might know
these better as magic mushrooms, starting at about
100 milligrams. And then slowly working up to
about, I want to say it was 600 or so milligrams,
which just is reasonably high. It's far above
what one would consider a microdose. Microdose,
let's just call it 50 to 100 milligrams.
And simultaneously, I'm having this first
experience of being silent for effectively
the entire day, maybe outside of asking
a question or two at a Dharma talk at night.
This is brand new. And what ended up happening,
just to jump to the punchline, is around —
I was having difficulty with the meditation,
to begin with. I was very physically
uncomfortable. My mind began to accelerate in
terms of just rumination. The velocity of thought,
and velocity implies a direction, it was more like
a ping pong ball bouncing around, or a pinball
bouncing around in a machine at increasing speed,
sort of nonlinear exponentially growing speed, and
it was very uncomfortable. And then I want to say,
around day four or five, I had this
flooding of memories of childhood abuse,
and it wasn't just snapshots. It was like being
stuck in a fully immersive VR experience that
was as convincing as this reality, whenever I
closed my eyes. So whenever I closed my eyes,
that's what I saw. It was a re-experiencing of
these traumatic experiences from age two to four.
And if people go to tim.blog/trauma, they can
listen to a podcast about this, and certain
modalities that helped me. But nonetheless, I did
not expect this, and I was utterly incapable of
stopping it. I could not stop it, and this went —
talk about not sleeping, anytime I closed my eyes,
so I couldn't sleep. So, now what do you have? You
have compounding lack of sleep, and I had never
heard of this before. I didn't think this was a
possibility. I certainly thought it was a unique
experience, unique to me. I should be able to
figure this out. But eventually got so desperate,
I was like, "I'm not going to be able to function.
I mean, I am able to navigate my day-to-day here
right now with extreme pain, but I have no
confidence I'll be able to go back to normal
life and make decisions, manage my business,
interact in all the ways that are necessary."
And that's when I set up meeting with Jack, and
thankfully, he had the experience. He has a lot
of experience also as a clinical psychologist
with cutters, with people who've been abused,
with veterans who have lost limbs, and have moral
injuries, and PTSD. He has a lot of mileage with
many different patients, and clients, and
meditators, so he was able to, thank God,
provide a safety net, and provide me with
recommendations to clinicians, and so on,
therapists I could meet to try to address this.
But if he had not been there, I shudder to think
what would've happened. So, that's the story,
and ultimately was able to pull out of it, and
manage life. But not everyone has access to Jack.
And the contrast, and I'll shut up in a second,
between my day-to-day over the last two weeks,
all upside, and that experience are just black
and white. I mean, there's really no comparison.
Interestingly, and I'll add one more thing,
I recently spent a week in isolation in the
wilderness, fasting for that entire week,
and it was not nearly as challenging. But
I did see some similar symptoms, let's say,
in terms of that increased speed of the pinball
bouncing around in my head, as did another person
I was with, so two for two, without any attempt
to meditate, which raises all sorts of questions,
right? So it's hard for me to parse what
caused what I experienced, but I know that
it was terrible, and without Jack, I would've been
fucked, for lack of a better technical term. How
common is that kind of experience, I guess? And
certainly feel free to start wherever you'd like,
or pick that apart in any way that makes sense.
But it was a disaster, unmitigated disaster,
and I'm very fortunate I had someone like Jack.
Because I had actually spoken with one other
just junior teacher at the time, and she was
unequipped, she was not equipped to handle what
was happening, but Jack was.
Willoughby Britton: Yeah,
so many different thoughts.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you for coming to my TED Talk.
Willoughby Britton: I mean, one is just
wow, and wow in so many ways. Wow that
that happened to you, and two, that you're
talking about it, publicly. That's amazing. So,
thank you, because I think it's going
to be really helpful to a lot of people.
Tim Ferriss: My pleasure.
Willoughby Britton: Maybe a second thought is,
you're definitely not alone. You're definitely
not the only one. There were probably other people
on your retreat that this was happening to, and
that in my work at Cheetah House, I see someone
like that every day. I try to see at least one
person every day. I'm seeing someone later today,
actually. So this, to me, is my bread and butter.
I see it all the time. It's so common. But what
are the actual percentages? That's where
we get into the rabbit hole of research,
and frequency research, which is actually quite
complicated, because it's about like, "Well, what
do you mean by this?"
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Willoughby Britton: "And frequent among who?" And
so, it becomes more complicated. And I guess one
other question is, given what I do, that I'm
an expert on meditation-related challenges,
and neurobiology, is there anything that we
can talk about that would be useful to you to
sort of make sense of? Do you have any lingering
questions that haven't been answered yet? So I'll
just put that out there. And then another thing
is, let's create a public service announcement
for people like you, because let me tell you,
males 18 to 30 who think that combining every
possible powerful tool, all at once, to break on
through to the other side is a story that I see
again over, and over, and over again.
Tim Ferriss: That doesn't always turn
out well, you're saying?
Willoughby Britton: No,
it's more like a risk factor.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah, for sure.
Willoughby Britton: And so we'll see like — at
Cheetah House, we have a program called "Letters
to My Former Self," where people come on, who
did stuff like that, and then they're like,
"Honey, let me tell you what I wish I'd known
when I was your age." You tell your former
self advice, I would love you to do that.
Tim Ferriss: There should also be a letter
to your future self, so you don't do the same
thing again. I do have a couple of questions,
or a few observations, and a couple of questions.
So, looking back at that experience separately,
prior to that experience, and afterwards,
I had a lot of experience with fasting,
including extended fasts, and a lot of experience
with psychedelics, and that was pre-meditation
retreat, and certainly post. Based on my last
experience over the last three weeks, where I
was in isolation in the wilderness, fasting and
so on. I tend to wait, in this particular case,
the fasting as an exacerbating factor more
than the microdosing of psychedelics, which
is not to recommend to anyone that they combine
things on their first meditation retreat. Look,
there are lots of meditation retreats, do it
the plain vanilla way first would be my strong
recommendation. It's going to be hard enough,
don't worry, would be recommendation number one.
There are some people, and this is going to
lead to my question, like Yuval Noah Harari,
who wrote Sapiens, who I've had on the podcast,
who does a silent meditation retreat for a month
every year, as far as I can tell, and handles it
like a champion. It is like a warm bath for his
mind. I found it much harder — I'm sure there are
people who find it harder. My question is this,
what are the, not necessarily exclusionary
criteria, but what are some of the characteristics
or profiles that make someone more vulnerable
or likely to have this type of experience?
Because for instance, if you look at classical
psychedelics, and we could spend a lot of time
defining what that means, but broadly speaking
let's just say with the usual suspects that a
lot of people would recognize, let's say LSD,
psilocybin, et cetera, there are certainly others,
ayahuasca could be thrown into this or
N,N-DMT, that if you have a family history
of schizophrenia, it is likely a bad idea for you
to engage with using these things simply because,
not to say that it will make you schizophrenic
in a lifetime where you would otherwise not
become schizophrenic, but it could expedite
the onset of symptoms. And there are many
documented cases of this.
So in a case that you
have a family history history of schizophrenia,
maybe you should not consume these things. And I'm
wondering how you would paint what the intake form
should look like, what does the intake look like
for a meditation retreat so that a facilitator
could say, you know what, I think maybe you should
do 20 minutes a day, or 30 minutes a day, but not
do seven days silent because that would be taking
ayahuasca for a schizophrenic. How would you
think about the things that make it more likely?
Willoughby Britton: This is a very natural place
to start, which is sort of screening out people
who shouldn't meditate. And now I'm going to
unpack why that's a very difficult thing to do.
I conducted a epidemiological study with
Richie Davidson and Simon Goldberg looking at
meditation-related adverse effects, how often they
happen, and risk factors. And so statistically
speaking there is an increased risk factor for a
large range of variables that would be considered
stressors, adversity. So trauma history, psych
history, being some kind of minority group,
whether it's racial minority or sexual
orientation minority, something like that,
is going to be a chronic stressor and that's
going to heighten the risk for adverse effects.
So it's very easy to just sort of, "Well, those
people shouldn't meditate." It's very easy to do
that. Well first of all, more than 90 percent of
people have exposure to a criterion A stressor,
so that would be almost everyone gets ruled out,
except for the extremely sheltered and privileged,
which would be not what we're trying to do with
meditation, is just limit it to those people.
And then in the Varieties of Contemplative
Experience study, we found that a lot of the
risk factors that were the most obvious ones
to consider, like psych and trauma history,
they didn't know what they were doing,
incorrect practice, that kind of thing,
that none of those actually panned out to
be true. And so in our study, 60 percent of
the people who had meditation-related challenges
were themselves meditation teachers, so they were
getting correct practice instructions, they were
meditating correctly, they had good supervision,
they had good knowledge about what to do, and
there were a number of people that did not have
psychiatric or trauma histories. So while those
are risk factors, it doesn't mean that if you
don't have them that you're safe.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Willoughby Britton: So the sort of take home
message from me is I'm not a big fan of screening
people out. I think the other side of this is
that there are a lot of people, and this might
be not as true for psychedelics as it is for
meditation, but meditation is being marketed
for schizophrenia, for psychosis, for bipolar
disorder, for all the things that you might,
as a retreat manager, want to red flag, so it
would be just a strange thing to start saying, oh,
those people can't have access to this technology.
And I've gotten letters from people that say,
"Please don't just rule us out," people with
what would be considered serious mental illness,
"Please don't just rule us out because we
seem like it would be a bad idea for us."
Tim Ferriss: Well, let me pause for one second
and just say, it seems to depend on the type
of meditation we're talking about, right? For
meditating 20 minutes in the morning, there
might be one intake, but for doing a seven-day
silent retreat there might be a different intake.
So I don't know if you're able to speak to that,
because those two things, I mean, had about as
much in common for me as playing with a Hot Wheels
car on the top of your kitchen table and driving
an F1 car around a hairpin turn.
Willoughby Britton: Right.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, they both involve cars, okay.
Willoughby Britton: Right, I guess my point is
is that I think that the action item here is not
screening people out as much as being much more
informed about how to monitor them closely and
how to have more off-ramps as part of the retreat.
Tim Ferriss: I want to give people, just
so not everyone is like, "Oh, my God,
the next time I meditate am I going to have a
psychic implosion and end up in a straightjacket!"
Just to put some numbers to things, I want
to read something here and just have you
fact check this so people have some numbers on
prevalence, and also just a comparative parallel
of sorts that we'll spend a little bit of time
on. Then I want to talk about safety training,
monitoring, and off-ramps, and things like that.
So this is from mindfulnessexercises.com, which
is pulling from an interview with you:
"With a more clear definition of adverse
effects in hand, Willoughby and her team set out
to research the true prevalence of life-impacting
adverse effects following meditation. The
first surprising result was that their
epidemiological sample indicated nearly half of
the US population has meditated at least once."
I'm sure that's higher now. "Of these people,
six to 14 percent had lasting negative effects."
So that's what I wanted to bring up, a number
that closely mirrors the adverse effects of
psychotherapy, five to 13 percent. Is
that roughly accurate, would you say?
Willoughby Britton: Frequency research is
very challenging, and so I do think that the
epidemiological study is probably the most valid
research, but somehow the data that they're citing
is actually from combining two different studies.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, got it.
Willoughby Britton: So the epidemiological
study, the denominator was anyone who's ever
meditated even once. So that's the lowest common
denominator, so the lowest possible chance. And
within that study we found that people who had
tried meditation even once, half of them would
have at least one negative effect. And it could
be extremely brief, no big deal. More concerning
is that 10 percent, so one in 10 people who
had tried meditation even once, would have a
meditation-related adverse effect that was
associated with impairment in functioning.
And so we can go down the rabbit hole of
definitions if you want, but I think that for me,
having a negative experience during meditation,
which we call negative valence, I don't consider
that an adverse effect. I think that if you don't
have some kind of negative experience in your
meditation at some point you're probably sleeping,
because it's not a warm bath for the mind,
it can be challenging. So I'm not worried about
that part, but I'm more worried about if it has
a negative impact on your life and functioning
off the cushion, then I'm like, okay, that's when
we need to start talking about whether there's
maybe alternatives. And so one in 10 is really
the number that is jumping out of that paper.
The other paper, which was a clinical trial
that I did, much smaller trial, very selected
sample of people who have clinical to subclinical
anxiety and depression, that came up with
the five to 15 percent, which is still, they
correlate with each other, but yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So what are some things
that we can do to risk mitigate in terms of, and
you can pick whichever makes sense to start with,
but training for instructors, or monitoring. I'm
actually pretty interested in the monitoring,
I'm interested in all of it. And then
off-ramps, what to do if somebody does
have a break, I suppose, like I did. I wouldn't
necessarily describe it as a psychotic break,
but I felt out of control. I felt like I would
not be able to function normally had I returned
to normal life without some intervention. What
can we do to make things safer, I suppose?
Willoughby Britton: I think it helps to start
with, we created a taxonomy of 59 categories
of meditation-related challenges, and it
wasn't until many years later that I went
through the somatic experiencing trauma training
that I started to actually see a lot of those 59
categories in terms of trauma symptoms, and in
terms of symptoms of the way that the body tends
to react to extreme stress. And that these are
not necessarily so altered states, but things
that might be somewhat recognizable to people.
So one of the ways that I think is the most
efficient way, because we can train meditation
teachers and be like, I have online courses
where you're like, they have quizzes on the
59 categories, and there's all this content
that they need to learn. But I actually think
that the best way to do it is to train each
individual person to be like, Tim, how do you
know when you're getting outside of your window
of tolerance? How do you know when you're feeling
"out of control?" What is your indicator for that?
Tim Ferriss: It's when I seem incapable, or
maybe when I am incapable, of stopping very
high-speed negative rumination, I suppose. It
would be perseverating on either a real event,
like a memory, or a perceived threat, like a
hypothetical worst case scenario, and I just loop
and loop and loop and loop. And I'm furthermore
aware of the looping, right? There's part of me
as the observer that's like, holy shit, I can't
believe I seem incapable of stopping this. I know
it's not productive, I know it's not helping
me, and yet it just goes and goes and goes.
That would be my canary in the coal mine, or
maybe a flock of canaries in the coal mine.
Willoughby Britton: So is there anything
that is an earlier indicator than that,
before you get there?
Tim Ferriss: I would say it's
more I've realized which factors can contribute
to that. It's something for me that comes on,
so this may be a dissatisfying answer, but it's
something that can come on really suddenly, but
I would say that overcaffeination, lack of sleep,
fasting, there are a handful of things that seem
more likely to precipitate this type of experience
than other things. It doesn't happen all the time,
but I would say probably, if I were to try
to back into what I described, I'm sure that
it starts with, and I'm sure it started, I have
to imagine, at my Vipassana retreat with having
bouts of this come up and then trying to suppress
it, I'm sure it took some form like that. I would
have to imagine it was something like that.
Willoughby Britton: So, just to quid pro
quo, I mean, I have lots of them, but
I think my mouth gets dry, is like an
indication of sympathetic activation.
Tim Ferriss: Very interesting, yeah.
Willoughby Britton: I get really hot, and when
I'm really about to, a strong stressor for me is
when my visual field starts to get wonky,
and that's when the dissociation sets in.
Things get a little spacey, like that.
So if this was a meditation class,
I would have everyone go around and talk about
their own personal indicators. Because no matter
how much research we do, those indicators
are, there's going to be a lot of overlap,
but there are also going to be some individual
differences. And really what matters is that
the person knows what their indicators are,
they're like, okay, my system is stressed,
don't keep doing what you're doing that's making
this happen, let's dial it back. And unfortunately
the response is often, well just keep going,
just keep meditating, keep doing whatever
you're doing, at some point there's going to be
a breakthrough, but instead it just gets worse.
So that is more of the angle that I'm taking,
is teaching everybody what their indicator
lights are. Just like you don't get in
a car and drive until you know, okay,
the gas meter's here, this is the tire pressure,
you have these indicator lights, and we have them,
we have indicator lights, and we all need
to be trained on what they are individually.
And that will keep you a lot safer when
you know what your indicator lights are.
I think one of the things that undermines that is
this fascination and romanticization of altered
states. And you can think of altered
states as a deviation from baseline,
a deviation from homeostasis, which is, in trauma
speak, that is dysregulation. An altered state
is not necessarily something that you want to be,
it's not necessarily a good idea for someone who's
trying to stay stable. And so just having people
be able to track that and, okay, that thing, my
indicator light, is on, what typically helps that?
And go do that. I need to go lift some weights,
I need to go dial back and I need to skip the
coffee this afternoon, or maybe eat something.
By the way, the fasting thing is really, really
interesting. We had a lot of information in the
varieties project about diet, but we really
hadn't done anything with it, and actually one
of my students this year has just started to delve
into the diet data and is finding that it's really
making a difference. That a lot of people have
reported that when you go on meditation retreats,
because they tend to be vegetarian and
they tend to feed you very light food,
sometimes not even, sometimes there's no dinner.
And so it's not fasting so much, but it's
definitely like you're going off of your, like my
personal high protein diet, I get very unregulated
and floaty and ungrounded when I go on retreats
and I really want to have heavy food. And so a
lot of people found that to be a factor, and found
that actually eating really high fat protein meat
is a remedy for the problems. And this is also
recommended within Tibetan medicine, and old
Buddhist textual reports will also report eating
meat and heavy foods, oils can also be something
that can help bring people down and more grounded.
And when we interviewed the teachers as teachers,
which was the second part of the study, there
was really not a lot of consensus about what
was a problem, what wasn't a problem, what was
a risk factor, what wasn't. But there were two
things, and one was when the person stops
sleeping and when the person stops eating,
that's when you intervene. So those were the
two things that people, all teachers, mentioned
as being something that they worry about.
Tim Ferriss: So let me hop in for a second just
to mention something that I found in the process
of doing homework for this. This was actually a
Harper's piece about you and your team, and it
discussed something that I've also seen, which
does not really get discussed, so I'm bringing
it up very deliberately, post certain potent
psychedelic experiences. So this is something that
I've seen in both, well actually I should say now
I've seen described here as an
adverse effect of meditation,
possibly, for some folks, and also I've seen this
post-psychedelic. And this is, I'll just read:
"'Practicing letting go of concepts,' one
meditator told Britton, 'was sabotaging my mind's
ability to lay down new memories and reinforce old
memories of simple things, like what words mean,
what colors mean.'" What I'm going to underline
is what's coming next: "Meditators also reported
diminished emotions, both negative and positive.
'I had two young children,' another meditator
said. 'I couldn't feel anything about them. I went
through all the routines, you know: the bedtime
routine, getting them ready and kissing them and
all of that stuff, but there was no emotional
connection. It was like I was dead.'"
So this anhedonia, let's call it,
which interestingly can also be, for some people,
addressed with psychedelics, but what's less
talked about is that it can be initiated in some
people by psychedelics, where they come out and
they're sort of numb to the world. People
think of the amygdala as this fear center,
but it's not exactly a fear center. So maybe you
could just speak to this particular manifestation
of issue, because I've seen it in both camps.
Willoughby Britton: Yeah, so there's kind of
two different ways that this can happen with
meditation and psychedelics. With meditation,
if you look at the neuroscience of meditation,
and there's lots of different kinds, but we'll
just say concentration practice, you tend to see a
downregulation of the limbic system, the amygdala,
and activation of the prefrontal cortex. So
attention system goes up, downregulates the limbic
system. And again, this can be great, good things,
you regulate all your anxiety and depression.
But if you keep going, then you're going to see
a downregulation of not just negative emotions,
but also positive ones. People forget that the
amygdala is a salience detector for all sorts of
things, positive and negative, and you're going
to see, if you continue to downregulate your
limbic system with meditation, and you take
it far enough, then you will see a decrease
in the intensity of all emotions, otherwise
known as anhedonia. According to [inaudible],
that could also be something that could be
equanimity. So it depends on what you want.
Tim Ferriss: Tomato, tomato, right?
Willoughby Britton: Yeah. Obviously the person
who didn't feel anything for her children, that
was not her goal. But I actually, that particular
quote that you're reading, I read that quote in a
conference and a Buddhist scholar jumped up at the
end and said, "Cutting attachments, affection
with your families, is exactly what you're
supposed to be doing." And so I was like, "Okay,
well, we need to talk about what your goals are."
Tim Ferriss: Thou doth protest too much.
Willoughby Britton: So with meditation,
there is overlap, so what's interesting about
that model, prefrontal cortex control over the
limbic system, is that that's also the
neuroscience of dissociation. So there
are certain forms of meditation that mimic the
exact neurobiology of dissociation, so that's
one way to end up in this place.
The other way, so I call that the low road,
because you're just basically just taking
everything down, getting calmer and calmer
and calmer. The high road is the one we were
talking about earlier where you're training
your attention and everything's upregulating
and you're getting more and more and more,
your thoughts are racing and you're having
flooding of traumatic experiences and
everything's getting heightened. And at some
point your system's like, "Whoa, this is too
much," and you have this beautiful, adaptive,
natural breaker switch called dissociation
that will basically take the heightened, it'll
basically shut down the limbic system again,
and you'll basically end up in the state, the
first state that I just talked about, where you
have a strong activation of the prefrontal cortex
and a downregulation of the limbic system. And
so it's two different roads to the same place.
And so what's interesting, and the overlap with
psychedelics, is that too much response that can
lead to dissociation, it doesn't always have to
be negative. People can have a euphoric unitive
experience where they merge with the universe,
or they have just something just ecstatic kind
of experience, but their organism is like,
"That was too intense. That was too much for me.
I'm turning on the breaker." And they wake up in
the morning and they feel dead, and they spend
years trying to recreate that awesome experience,
but they're not really listening to their
organism's message, which is saying, "That was too
intense. Are you listening?" And so they go back.
And so we actually see a lot of people, there is
a very interesting overlap at Cheetah House when
people come for help, we see the combination of
psychedelics and meditation very often, a lot
of times in this scenario, where they go on a
meditation retreat, have an ecstatic experience,
or just a very intense experience, wake up feeling
dead and anhedonic, and they think, "I've got
to sort of shock the system back into action and
they go take a psychedelic." And that just makes
things worse because the system's like, "I've been
trying to tell you that this is too much and
now you're just really pushing the envelope."
In the end we also see the opposite, people who
have the initial experience on psychedelics and
then they decide, "Well, I'm very dysregulated,"
and they get told by various authorities,
"You should go on a meditation retreat,"
or, "You should meditate." Either way,
at least the people who show up at Cheetah House,
the combination was not the answer for them.
Tim Ferriss: Let me hop in for a second just
to ask a few follow-up questions on retreat
specifically. Are there any intensive retreats
that you recommend, or extended retreats? And I
suppose the broader question is how can one
know where to practice and vet properly if
someone wants to do a meditation retreat?
And the reason I ask is, for instance,
with psychedelics, which are still
largely underground at this point,
even though at some point hopefully there
will be an entire framework for administering
them reasonably safely to people who fit certain
criteria, if someone finds a facilitator who says,
"I've never had — no one under my care has ever
had a bad trip," that is a huge red flag because
it means they're either deluding themselves,
they're lying, or they're really inexperienced.
Those are kind of the only options on the table
because you're effectively using nuclear power
to change the plasticity of the mind, of course,
there are going to be adverse events, of course
there are going to be outliers, and so you want
someone who has actually handled those cases.
If you go to, to push my F1 analogy, if you go
to a racetrack, let's just say, and you're going
to a track day, and the track owner says, "We've
never had any accident of any type on our track,"
that's a bad thing because someone's going to
have an accident, you want to make sure they have
protocols in place, they have experience, they
have the presence of mind to handle it calmly,
et cetera, et cetera. So I could see that
applying also to vetting meditation retreats.
But putting myself in the position of someone
listening to this, they might say, "Holy shit,
of the people who have tried meditation once,
X percentage of these persistent problems,
this seems really, really dangerous, maybe I just
shouldn't meditate." So for those people, to maybe
offset that a little bit, are there retreats
that you ever recommend? And how can someone
vet if they're considering doing a retreat?
Willoughby Britton: Yeah, wow. I mean,
I think that a lot of it has to do with
matching the goals to the person. So I don't
want to necessarily rule out or recommend
any particular retreat across the board.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Willoughby Britton: I think that
there are certain retreats that are pretty repeat
offenders, and those are ones that have high dose,
like 15 hours of meditation a day, no movement
practice. So often you see an alternation between
walking and sitting, and sometimes there's
even yoga added. So more intense practices
with no movement, and also not necessarily
tailored feedback from teachers. So I would
be very careful before going on one of those.
And I think, just in general, there are so many
different options for retreats these days, you
can do an afternoon retreat where it's only a
couple hours, start there, titrate up, see
how it is. And you can do this at home, you
don't even have to necessarily spend the money,
you can just download an app and do that for a
day and see how you do. Titrate up and just do it
one, add a day at a time if you're worried about,
rather than signing up for a 10-day retreat.
Tim Ferriss: There's something I have
not mentioned before is that I've
done shorter meditation retreats,
like two or three days, with no issues whatsoever.
So I just want to point that out. The other fine
detail that I want to mention, because I
think Spirit Rock runs a very good ship,
and I think they're very well-formatted and they
do have safeguards in place that they explicitly
advise against fasting, and I violated that rule.
I overrode that, and also added the psychedelics,
which certainly I had not mentioned to
anyone until I had already capsized.
Willoughby Britton: Yeah, this never used to be
an issue, but I know that people are doing that,
that people are bringing psychedelics on retreats.
And I think a lot of the retreats, they have to
manage a lot of people, and people are already
having challenging experiences, the regular kind
of challenging experiences with meditation, and
so to have to manage people who are also taking
psychedelics, that's a lot, it's not really
fair to a meditation retreat. So I think that —
Tim Ferriss: No, it's going to be invisible
to them, for the most part, I'm sure,
right? It's not going to be reported. Just like
people lie on their medical intakes about the
psychiatric medications they're taking if
they are wedded to taking psychedelics with
a facilitator. This happens all the time, people
misrepresent their health status because they're
so vested in this last Hail Mary, "Obi-Wan Kenobi,
you're our final hope" solution panacea that they
see in psychedelics, and I have to imagine
that also happens with meditation retreats.
I should also say, I'd love for you to say a
bit more about repeat offenders. Are there any
other characteristics or format issues that
you see producing more problems than others
outside of what you already mentioned?
Willoughby Britton: So in terms of the
retreat or meditation type, or in
terms of personal risk factors?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that seems to produce, the
retreat or meditation type that seemed to produce
a higher volume of people with these issues.
Willoughby Britton: So I would say retreats
that recruit or are attracting a certain type
of meditator, which by the way, you fit the
bill pretty exactly. When I heard this story
I was like, wow, that's pretty emblematic of —
Tim Ferriss: Textbook.
Willoughby Britton: Yeah. Young male,
pretty educated, combining all sorts of tools,
fairly aggressive. We used to joke that one of
the risk factors was zealotry, a kind of zealotry,
a zeal, so something like that. And so people,
there's a certain kind of, almost like military,
this is going to be a really, really hard retreat,
those types of retreats are a little bit
more high-risk. And I think there's also the
combination of the person and the teacher/format.
And so for people who are — so one of the things
that we found that was really shocking in the
Varieties of Contemplative Experience study
is that on one hand, we expected to see people
who ran into problems, as people who had lots of
problems in their lives. But when we actually
looked at the data, 75 percent had graduate
degrees, MD, PhDs, JDs. These were CEOs of major
companies. These are super high-achieving people,
and we were like, "This is so interesting. How
do we make sense of that?" And we're like, "Oh,
right, being a high achiever is a risk factor."
Tim Ferriss: I was just about to say that drug
addiction in the medical profession
is suicides off the charts. Right.
Willoughby Britton: It's because these are
the kinds of people that you're like, "Okay,
we're going to sit and follow your breath," and
they're like, "Okay." They're the ones that show
up early for the meditation and they're the
last ones to leave. They're the ones that are
like — they follow instructions exactly, and they
would never modify the instructions for their own
benefit. That would not even occur to them.
Tim Ferriss: Unless they make it more intense.
Willoughby Britton: This is kind of where
trauma comes in. If you've been trained to scan,
what are the expectations here? What are
the unspoken social rules that I need to
ace in order to not be punished? If that's
kind of your MO running in the background,
then we have all these people following
instructions exactly, not modifying them.
Basically, listening to an external authority
rather than their own internal compass, that's
the recipe for disaster, so if you can interface
with, really, any type of meditation spiritual
system with maintaining your inner compass, that's
going to be a recipe for a much better outcome.
But not everybody can do that and
not all systems are tolerant of that,
so I would also encourage — we've had lots of
trainings with meditation centers, trying to be
able to be more flexible. So if somebody knows,
"I need to be able to leave the meditation in the
middle so that I'm not continuing to meditate,"
and the meditation retreat manager is like, "No,
that won't be allowed. You have to stay. If you
come, you have to stay for the whole thing,"
that's not really allowing flexibility. So are
there ways that people can titrate the amount
of practice that they're getting within a retreat?
Is there a way to like, "Hey, on Wednesday, we'll
have burger night for people who need to increase
the fat intake." That is actually happening now.
Tim Ferriss: The vegetarian diet piece is super
interesting. I mean, I don't know if the sort of
acuity is sufficient as a factor, but it makes me
think also, for instance, some of these conditions
that are, let's just say, contraindicated
for most psychedelic use, schizophrenia,
borderline personality disorder, understanding
these are all kind of word salad things taken from
the DSM, which is kind of a big question mark
for a lot of reasons. But some of these more,
for lack of better terms, sort of chaotic
conditions or contraindicated, respond really
well to something called metabolic psychiatry. And
Chris Palmer has spoken about this out of Harvard,
using effectively ketogenic diet but high-fat,
moderate protein, some of these people respond
incredibly well. So if you look though at
the food served at these meditation retreats,
uniformly effectively the exact polar
opposite, which is kind of interesting.
Do you meditate? Do you meditate now,
or is that not a practice for you?
Willoughby Britton: Ooh, that's a long,
long story. It depends on what you —
Tim Ferriss: All right. Let's do it.
Willoughby Britton: It depends on what
you mean by meditate.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Willoughby Britton: Meditation, when I
first undertook it with Jack's sort of
meditation, it came from a specific tradition
and it had a whole bunch of implicit goals
and values that weren't really clear to me
because I was just suffering. So I thought,
I'm just going to do this so I won't feel so much
panic and anxiety and et cetera. So I've done
tens of thousands of hours of meditation. I've
been part of meditation. I've been the expert
meditator in many brain imaging studies. I've done
my time as a Buddhist meditator, but I've started
to understand that there's a whole set of implicit
values that I didn't necessarily choose, so —
Tim Ferriss: What would be an
example, if you don't mind?
Willoughby Britton: Well, an example is that the
ideal effect or the goal emotion state is more on
the calm end of things.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Willoughby Britton: And as a direct
descendant of General George S. Patton,
it's not really in my blood to be calm.
Tim Ferriss: More of a border
collie, and less of a great Dane. Yeah.
Willoughby Britton: Yeah. Anyway,
there's lots of people who their ideal state is
not calm. Yeah. There's lots of implicit values,
and I think that this is just something,
as meditation is moving into the West and
kind of mixing with a lot of different cultures
and subcultures and goals and values, can these
contemplative practices be used for many different
types of goals, rather than ones that were preset
as part of a religious practice? And I think that
is happening, but for myself in particular, I have
specific practices that I do, that I feel I have
permission now from myself to modify a practice
to not just follow the rules the way that I did
before and end up somewhere that I didn't want
to go, but rather to modify things and make sure
that I'm going where I want to go. But that also
requires me to actually sit down with myself
and be like, "Where do you want to go," which
is another thing that I recommend for people.
Before, Aimee Mann has a song, "Write down what
you need before you sign away the deed." Make
sure you know what you want because you're going
to get on a highway and it's going to be kind of
fast-tracking you to somewhere, making sure that
you are actually going where you want to go.
Tim Ferriss: I want to know what practices
that you follow. Not to imply that
anyone should just copy/paste,
right? You've got to know your own needs, but I
am curious where you've landed personally. You
tell me. Where would you like to start?
Willoughby Britton: I want to go to the
Varieties of Contemplative Experience. This
was the study that took us 10 years, and we
came up with 59 categories of meditation-related
challenges and adverse effects, and we categorize
them into seven different domains, cognitive,
perceptual, affective which is emotional,
somatic, conative which is motivational, sense
of self, and social. I'm not going to go through
all 59. People can look them up. They're on
the Cheetah House website under Symptoms.
But just to give you a sort of basic
overview of what is in each category,
cognitive types of experiences are increased in
thought frequency which you talked about, trouble
with executive functioning, so making decisions,
paying attention. The loss of conceptual meaning
structures, which you also mentioned. Probably
the most famous example is the woman who,
on the way back from retreat, stopped at a red
light, saw the red color, but didn't register
what it meant that it meant stop.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, boy.
Willoughby Britton: You
can see how that would be —
Tim Ferriss: Problematic.
Willoughby Britton: Sometimes
you need your concepts.
Tim Ferriss: Executive function? You
need your concepts?
Willoughby Britton: That's the cognitive domain.
Perceptual, you see perceptual hypersensitivity.
You can also see hallucinations, visions, changes
in perception, also changes in derealization,
so feeling like you're in a dream or things feel
flat or cartoon-like. Emotions can go in either
direction which you've already kind of touched on,
so increases in fear and panic and reexperiencing
of trauma, but also affect of blunting,
so loss of emotions altogether. You can also see,
in the somatic domain, ELSEs, energy-like somatic
experiences. We have an entire paper on that.
Tim Ferriss: Wait, say that again.
What does that stand for?
Willoughby Britton: ELSEs,
energy-like somatic experiences, so —
Tim Ferriss: What was that?
Willoughby Britton: — experiences of
electricity or voltage going through the
body. We talked about insomnia already and
lots of different kinds of pain syndromes,
headaches, different kinds of pains.
In terms of conative or motivational,
again, insane, just enlightenment or bust kind
of changes in motivation like, "Sorry, honey,
I'm gone. I'm going to go shave my head and become
a monk." We see that all the time. And then,
the opposite like complete loss of motivation.
"Why would I do anything?" No goals whatsoever.
The sense of self domain is my personal favorite.
I teach an entire class on it called "Me, Myself,
and I," but there's lots of changes in senses of
self and that can range from the narrative self,
the story of me, your identity self, all the
way down to your sense of ownership over your
own body, over body sensations, emotions,
thoughts. And then, also down to your sense
of self-other or self-world boundaries can
dissolve which we have a whole paper on that
as well. Obviously, there's a lot of overlap
with psychedelics with that particular category,
so we can unpack that if you want.
And then, within the social domain,
not surprisingly, if you're having these
experiences, it can be related to all kinds
of social consequences. People don't like hearing
about this. They have all sorts of reactions. Wait
till you get your responses to this episode.
Tim Ferriss: I want to talk about the Dalai
Lama too, before we get too far.
Willoughby Britton: People don't
like to hear about this. So a lot of people get
shunned by their communities. Sometimes their
teachers get irritated with them, and then
there's also trying to go to work and trying
to explain why you can't function. So, there's
all sorts of social dynamics that go with that.
That was kind of the quick and dirty overview of
the 59 categories. And I will say that within that
particular study, the Varieties of Contemplative
Experience study, we looked at duration of
symptoms and duration of impairment, and duration
of impairment, the average was one to three years.
So, it was quite a bit of time, and it ranged from
a few days to more than a decade, and I think in
your experience, you can kind of understand
why. It could be quite a long time before you
recover. If you don't happen upon Jack Kornfield
for a while, it could be quite a long time.
Tim Ferriss: Yes. I won the lottery on that latter
part of things. The duration you're describing,
I just want to draw a couple of parallels.
I mean, you alluded to this, but you could
take almost everything you just mentioned if
not everything, and map it to adverse events
related to psychedelic experiences, pretty much
everything. I think everything that you mentioned.
And in terms of duration, there's something that
doesn't get talked about very much also because
it is viewed as perhaps risking the cause and
the momentum of the psychedelic renaissance,
but there's something. It's a bit of a
mouthful. I wish it had a better name,
but HPPD, Hallucinogen Persisting Perception
Disorder. I know people who've experienced
this where they are effectively hallucinating
on some level for years. I have a family member
who experienced this by marriage, and I have a
very close friend who experienced this for the
second half of his undergrad and for several years
afterwards. People can find more on this online.
I suppose we could move into scaffolding,
but I'd like to ask you, are there any
particular distinctions, clear differences
between meditation-related adverse events
and psychedelic-related adverse events?
Willoughby Britton: Well, we don't really
know. That's actually a study that we're in the
middle of collecting data on. I'm glad that you
mentioned that there's a lot of overlaps because
I'm also seeing them, and a lot of people that
have had both experiences are mentioning that
there is a lot of overlap. The study that we're
conducting is basically looking at all of the
meditation-related, basically seeing how much
they overlap and whether there are systematic
differences. If I had to guess, I would say that
the perceptual changes, the HPPD-like changes,
would be more common in the psychedelic world.
I do think there's something neurological going
on there that might be not happening in all
forms of meditation, but we definitely see visual
snow and lots of — there can be some perceptual
changes that are enduring, visual changes that are
enduring. But if you look at the HPPD literature,
it's actually a lot more than just visual changes.
There's a whole lot of different things going on.
So, I think that's a really interesting question,
not how they compare, but also whether somebody's
a dual user and whether it's changing that way.
Tim Ferriss: A lot of people are dual users. Yeah.
It's very hard to disambiguate. The resource
I want to recommend, and I can't vouch for it
personally because fortunately I do not have
HPPD, but the more people use these compounds,
meaning psychedelics of various types, the more
this is going to become prevalent and really
need proper addressing. There is a website. It's
perception.foundation, and that's the Perception
Restoration Foundation. They have resources. They
have frequently asked questions about HPPD. They
have a documentary trailer. They also have a
specialist directory. I cannot vouch for the
capabilities of any of the specialists, but a lot
of people who experience this feel the way I did
in the midst of my silent retreat, which is, "I
am broken. I don't know how to fix this. Everyone
else seems fine. I don't even know what to call
this," and there's a real sense of futility or
hopelessness that can come with that. So, suffice
to say, the Perception Restoration Foundation may
be a place to start. I can't vouch for it,
but perception.foundation for folks who may
want to look that up. What is scaffolding?
Willoughby Britton: For people who come to
Cheetah House, and let me just back up a little
bit about the Cheetah House sort of origin story,
I mean, the actual Cheetah House started as a
halfway house for Brown students who wanted to
become monastics because of our contemplative
studies program. So kids will get meditation
training in school as part of college, and they
get so inspired by it that they want to go to
India and ordained as monks, and going there and
coming back, and living in dorms as a celibate,
non-intoxicant-taking college students doesn't
really work, so they lived at Cheetah House.
That was the original place. That was the
original function of Cheetah House was to
support semi-monastic Brown students.
Tim Ferriss: Is it true Cheetah
is a play on words, the name?
Willoughby Britton: Cheetah is a play on
words. It's a play on the Sanskrit term, citta,
which means, loosely, "mind." When we started
doing the Varieties of Contemplative Experience
study, we were interviewing a number of people
who were having meditation-related challenges, and
some of them had just gotten out of the hospital,
and they're like, "I'm 27 and I'm living with
my parents. Can I live with you?" I live at
Cheetah House, so this is my house. It's a big
Victorian house with lots of floors. So there
was an entire floor where meditators could live
and kind of recover from whatever was happening.
That was the beginning of Cheetah House.
It is now entirely online, and it is helping
people recover from meditation-related
challenges, and a number of them,
they are not able to meditate at all. They're
not able to engage in anything that looks like
meditation. All the trauma cues and associations
are around everything meditation, so sitting with
your eyes closed, sitting on a floor with your
legs crossed, using a soft voice and guidance,
all of that triggers the response.
Tim Ferriss: Trigger city.
Willoughby Britton: So basically, half of the
mental health world just becomes inaccessible
to these people because they go to a
therapist and the therapist is like,
"Oh, you need to do mindfulness." And they're
like, "No, not mindfulness, please. Anything
but mindfulness." So we have to figure out a
way to help people build their own practice.
And I think the other piece that I wanted to
unpack with you after I heard your podcast was
the term ideological power. Ideological
power is the power to control meaning,
language, and which concepts are available
and how they're used, the power to interpret
your own or others' experiences, behavior or
feelings, and the power to silence or undermine.
The important thing here is that trauma is
associated with powerlessness and a lack of
options and a lack of agency. So, for people who
have been traumatized by meditation or meditation
systems, any kind of system is also a form of
ideological power over them. Even CBT is a system,
any kind of therapy or model is a system,
so that also becomes something that they're
not able to work with because it feels
controlling. It feels like it's some kind
of value system or model that's being imposed
on them. So how do you work with that? This
is called person-centered approach.
So if you were my pretend client,
I would ask you, "Before you started meditating
or just outside of your meditation life,
what is something that is a resource for you?"
Tim Ferriss: Just for general well-being? Are
we talking about psychological
well-being as a resource?
Willoughby Britton: I mean, what I typically
do is actually ask you to look around where
you are right now and pick something
like a tangible object that's in your
immediate vicinity. That's something that's
meaningful to you but unrelated to meditation.
Tim Ferriss: Right. I was going to say, intense
exercise. I've told every girlfriend I've ever
had, "If you see me trying to sit down and
think my way through a problem for more than
a half hour, just tell me to go lift some
heavy stuff for an hour." It's just like,
"Tell me to get out of the house and go
exercise, and chances are, it'll resolve itself."
But if I'm looking for something meaningful
that is near me right now, there's quite a
bit here around me at the moment. I could say
there's an artist's sketchbook for working with
mostly graphite and ink where I do some drawing.
There is a copy of The Prophet by Kahlil Gibran,
which I read when I hop in the sauna. I'll just
read a couple pages frequently, and then put it
down. I can keep going, but those are two.
Willoughby Britton: As you're scanning the
environment, you'll notice that when I asked you
notice something that's meaningful, there's a
salience kind of skipping over certain areas but
glomming onto certain objects, but it's not that
the salience has a different flavor for each one.
So if you were going to think about, "I'm going
to take my nervous system in that direction," you
could actually start to chart where you could go,
different options. Just by looking at these
different objects, they're kind of telling
you like, "Oh, this will be activating. This will
be energizing. This will be calming. This will be
strength inducing." So, pick a direction. Where
would you want your nervous system to go? And
then, pick an object that goes with that.
Tim Ferriss: I'll choose the sketchbook
because that's where I am totally immersed
in something, present tense. I can get
lost in artwork. I don't think about whatever
mistake I made in a conversation yesterday. I
don't think about whatever bullshit I have to
handle tomorrow. I find that very nourishing
in a calming way, so I'll choose that.
Willoughby Britton: As I'm watching you,
I can see your eyes are kind of going somewhere
that's not anywhere in particular, which means you
have probably some images that are in your mind.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, maybe. I'm also looking at the
sketchbook that's directly past the
laptop, but we can work with that.
Willoughby Britton: Yeah. So, maybe more
generally, when you look at the sketchbook
and you're talking about it and you're
thinking about what it can do for you,
what are you noticing that goes with that?
Tim Ferriss: I would say just my sympathetic
nervous system seems to downregulate. Breathing
seems to slow a little bit. Hmm, if I'm being
totally honest, I have a small amount of anxiety
because I was really consistent with my art for
a while and I've lapsed for the last two months,
and I feel badly about it, some level of guilt,
but that's not what I'm going for.
Willoughby Britton: Yeah. Let me
just pause there. So, some kind of drop in
your sympathetic nervous system, how is that
manifesting? You said your breathing is starting
to calm down. What else is going with that? What
are other ways that you're noticing —
Tim Ferriss: Some muscular relaxation.
Willoughby Britton: Any particular area?
Tim Ferriss: Less tension. Yeah. Back,
neck. Those would be most obvious, I would say.
Less fidgety, right? Less bouncing of the foot.
Willoughby Britton: As you're looking at this
object, this sketchbook, and talking about it,
you're noticing that the sympathetic activation
is decreasing. It's changing your breathing.
There's something happening in your back that's
easing. And as I'm feeding this back to you,
what are you noticing that goes with that?
Tim Ferriss: I think it reinforces it. It's
not exactly positive reinforcement, but it sounds
like positive reinforcement for the relaxation,
so I'm able to settle into it, I suppose.
Willoughby Britton: This is kind of the
beginning of scaffolding. This is what it's like
because if I try to say like, "Okay, you're going
to focus on your breathing," or "I'm going to
give you an object to focus on," 50 percent of
people who are given the breath as an object of
meditation find that it is not the optimal — it's
not a safe object and it can actually induce
anxiety. So, if I have you pick the object,
I couldn't have picked that in a million years.
If I got to wander around your house and be like,
"Which thing should I pick," I wouldn't have been
able to pick something. You know immediately. You
have so much going on, and as a meditator, you're
able to feel into your environment. And there's
like, "Oh, wow, these have different flavors of
how they're actually impacting me." So I would
spend an hour with you unpacking one particular
object and I would be watching how your hands are
moving, and it would be certain kinds. You might
be like, "Oh, there's a story that goes with the
sketchbook," and you might end up on who gave you
the sketchbook, and it's really about that. So, we
kind of go down this rabbit hole together,
and I'm tracking your physiology with mine,
and if you're very, very dysregulated and
dissociated, and you're one of those people who
can't feel anything anymore, I can notice very
small changes in your physiology and be like,
"Hey, you remember that one thing that you just
said?" Because I saw your eyes brighten up a
little, I'll be able to specifically amplify
certain things, but I'm following your lead.
So, as somebody who's been very traumatized
about power dynamics and following any kind
of instructions feels like oppression and
feeling trapped in sort of some system,
if I'm following you and just reflecting back
to you what I'm seeing, that can be a little
bit more palatable to people who — that's kind of
what scaffolding is, and that's what we offer to
meditators who have basically developed
a trauma response to meditation itself,
which can really rule out a lot of things. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. That's an elegant
workaround/approach. And I would say that I feel
very fortunate that I don't personally, despite
the childhood experience with the abuse, have
that aversion to systems or coaches or teachers, I
think in part, because I'm such a problem student
in the sense that I just will constantly stop
things and question things, and I don't feel like
I need to take anything that is just off the rack,
so to speak. So, I feel very fortunate about that.
Let me return, since I made a promise to my
listeners and to myself that I would, to
your personal practices. What does your
self-care look like in that department? What
are those practices? Where have you landed?
Willoughby Britton: Well, I've been doing this
resourcing for a long time, this scaffolding,
and where it landed me, I started to realize
that in some ways not super surprising,
but I have a very strong reaction to
living things like animals and plants. So,
I started to realize how powerfully impacted my
gardening. I started getting really obsessed with
rare plants and growing them in a grow light.
Tim Ferriss: What kind of rare plants? Can
you name one? I'm so curious.
Willoughby Britton: Oh, just,
I don't know, weird tomatoes, things that you
can't buy in the grocery store. Just things that
you can't find otherwise. But basically where
I ended up was my husband and I bought 90 acres
in an undisclosed mountain area in Vermont, and
we built an off-grid cabin there, and it is so
awesome that I think I'm going to move to Vermont.
Tim Ferriss: Nice. Don't tell anybody.
Willoughby Britton: Oh, whoops, I just did it on
the Tim Ferriss podcast. But this exercise that we
just did, if that becomes the practice replacing
the hours a day that I did with Vipassana, with a
practice like that actually amplifying my positive
engagement with the world and what's in it, that
grew into something so beautiful and magnificent
as this place in the mountains. So it's not
just a technique that you do at your house in
order to perform better. It's just completely
taken over my life, so that's where I ended up.
Tim Ferriss: So it sounds almost epicurean in a
way like tending the garden, engaging with nature.
Willoughby Britton: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: Certainly, not to add the label
to it, I'm just saying that, do you find that
you derive the benefits you hope to derive from
meditation through this new engagement that you're
referring to? Or have your goals just change?
Willoughby Britton: If you wanted to paint a
picture of what my daily practice looks like,
imagine — I'm wearing actually my plaid shirt
sort of in commemoration of my Vermont self, but
imagine me putting on some Carhartt overalls and
getting a weed whacker or chainsaw and going
out and doing trail work. Even for the basic
idea of coming back and writing a paper or running
statistics or something, meditation never really
improved my cognition. I always found that I was
sort of one of those sleepy meditators. I would
just get really, really, really calm and my brain
just kind of got dull. But if I go out there and
just use power tools outside in the cold, then
I'm like, my blood's moving, my brain's working.
That's doing more of what I was hoping meditation
would do. I am also just ecstatically happy, which
meditation never did that for me. So there's that.
Tim Ferriss: Humans are built for movement. You've
got to move. The meditation's great, but it's for
me, very valuable. So I will say that small dose,
high frequency, high meaning twice a day, is very
strengthening to my life and my experiences. And
I spend four to five times minimum, as much
time moving every day. Right? The movement.
The movement is a critical piece of things.
Where can people find more information,
with respect to a class or training, related
to the meditation-related adverse effects?
Preventing them, mitigating them,
recovering from them, whether it's
as an individual or a facilitator/trainer.
Willoughby Britton: The public-facing sort
of service branch, info branch of my lab is at
Cheetah House, so that's cheetah, like the animal,
house, like a house, .org. And there's tons
of information on the website, lots of videos
and links to different kinds of symptom specific
resources. But if you're interested in training
specifically, on the Cheetah House website
there's a tab called online courses. If you're
a meditation teacher or a clinician, you can
actually take the courses. And there's a quiz and
it will give you, you can make sure that you know
the content. So there's more information there.
You can also just sign up for the Cheetah
House Newsletter, and that will alert you
to any of the kind of public lectures that
we have. We have one a month, and actually,
we have one today that's on SERT, which
is Spiritual, Existential, Religious,
and Theological Issues in Psychedelic-Assisted
Therapies by Roman Palitsky. So that's a good
one to see today. He just published an article in
JAMA about that topic and he'll be unpacking it
for people. So we do meditation-related
challenges, meditation-related issues,
but also psychedelics are becoming much more of a
topic. It's sort of, it's unavoidable that those,
the meditation and psychedelics are combining.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, absolutely. And I want to
zoom out for just a quick second and say that
— well, actually, let me volunteer something I
don't think I've said publicly, which is we've
been talking about, aside, among other things,
these adverse events, adverse effects that can
be associated with meditation. Different types,
different volumes and psychedelics. However, I
don't want to lose what I mentioned earlier. I
may have gotten the boundaries, the upper
and lower bounds wrong on the numbers,
but adverse events in psychotherapy.
After my experience at Spirit Rock,
I went to one of the most famous psychotherapists
who works with trauma in the world, and if I
mentioned his book, everyone would recognize
it who's in the trade, per se. And this guy
was one of the most narcissistic, unbelievably
unempathetic people I'd ever met in my life. And
he did a tremendous amount of damage. I met
with him twice for two individual sessions,
and his ego was so out of control and his
recommendations so intense and so flippant,
that it did a tremendous amount of damage. And
that took, this was related to the childhood
sexual abuse, and it took a long time to undo
the damage inflicted by a famous psychotherapist.
And I guess I wanted to bring this up to say
that when you engage with these mind-altering
modalities or consciousness altering modalities,
assume that you're dealing with power tools and
you need people who will admit that, "Yes,
you can cut fingers off if you use power
tools incorrectly." And furthermore, who have
lots of time not just working with clients,
but handling adverse events. And handling
them is not just an issue of capability,
it's also an issue of empathy and will.
So Danny Meyer, who's famous for Shake
Shack and hospitality and many different
restaurants, Gramercy Tavern, and others,
has this sort of matrix on the wall for employees
and it's The Will/Can Matrix. So just because
someone is a skilled psychotherapist does not mean
they're going to be willing to provide aftercare
or a safety net if you have an unraveling. So
it's to me, really important that you assess
practitioners in advance to ensure that they have
in fact handled these cases and feel very capable,
and have demonstrated competency
in handling these things calmly.
So I just want to say that because there's so
many fly-by-night rent-a-shamans running around,
and people who have done one yoga retreat and
had one or two psychedelic experiences who were
suddenly acting as on the road messiahs,
trying to proselytize everyone. And this
also goes for meditation. I know people who have
basically had what I would call psychotic breaks
pursuing Kundalini awakening, and then they are
suddenly traveling salespeople for endorsing this,
and they haven't yet even achieved stability for
themselves. This is really common. So just make
sure you're dealing with people who have handled
redline cases and have a clear demonstrative
track record, regardless of the modality.
Is there anything you'd like to add? Not
necessarily along those lines, but any
comments you'd like to make? I have more
questions. I do want to ask about NDEs.
Willoughby Britton: Oh, I forgot about
that part of my life.
Tim Ferriss: Oh,
I know. I take notes so I don't forget.
Willoughby Britton: I mean, one of the things
that we've learned at Cheetah House is that,
exactly that scenario that you're describing,
is that the helper professions can also be
the source of harm and trauma. This is called
institutional betrayal, when the people who
are supposed to be helping you are actually
the cause of harm. Then what happens when
you have not only trauma to meditation,
but trauma to all helping professions or helping
professionals? It really restricts your options.
And so there's other groups that do this,
too. We run a peer support model, because a
lot of people get to the point where they don't
trust anyone until they can sort of prove that,
"I was completely undone by this. I understand
what it's like to be leveled by this scenario."
And then you're like, "Okay, you get it. Now
I can talk to you." Because that empathy,
when you've been leveled that much, this is one
of the silver linings, is that you have so much
compassion and empathy when you've been leveled.
You really understand what that's like to be
in that place, to be a puddle on the ground.
So, that's one of the models that we have at
Cheetah House, and I think it really works, and
it works in two ways. One is that people feel
heard and validated, and not alone, because
they're like, they're being able to talk to
someone that this happened to as well, who's
also recovered. So they're like, "Oh, my God, I
can actually recover from this." And then for the
people who are offering care, they're like, "Wow,
I had this five-year hole in my life that was just
a hole that drained. It is just this thing, that
is not good for anything. And now I can actually,
it's something that's actually a gift I can give
to somebody else." And so every moment that they
spend with someone else is actually, is being
fueled by that trauma. So it's nice to be able to
have that trauma mean something and be useful in
some way, and not just be a drain on your life.
So that's another piece that I think is a nice
model that's out there. But yeah, I hear you with
the trouble finding a good therapist. Boy, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, there are a lot of clowns
running around all over the place. And just
to underscore the peer support, because you
reminded me of something. I'll put out a plea to
the psychedelic communities, which is if you have
not — this is also related to your getting leveled
comment. If you have not had at least 30 to 50
high-dose psychedelic experiences, you should
not be serving psychedelics to anyone. That'll
be statement number one. That would be a minimum.
And I'm not recommending people do anything
illegal, but I'm simply saying people are
going to do what people are going to do.
If you have not been tumbled and humbled
in a way that has left you questioning whether
you should ever touch these compounds again,
you are not in a position to administer to other
people. And the equivalent would be if you go
skiing once on the bunny slope and you happen not
to fall, and all of a sudden you're taking people
on heli-skiing trips without any type of guides
or airbags, because skiing is fun and helpful.
That is what I see all over the place.
So step number one is 30 to 50 minimum,
personally, because that'll give you a chance to
go skiing 50 times. And not only will you fall,
you'll have some bad falls and
you'll have different types of falls,
and then you'll be more informed on a
subjective level about the risks involved.
Then I would say secondly, you should, and this
connects to your peer support comment, volunteer
with an organization like Zendo at festivals
where the age range skews younger. Like lightning
in a bottle in other places, Zendo is peer-driven
harm reduction related to psychedelic, but really
drug consumption. And you get a decent amount of
training. It's pretty nominal, it's non-directive
support. So you're not trying to therapize people.
But, here's what I would suggest, is you volunteer
for the roughest shift, which is generally going
to be after midnight. And, if you're capable and
you should determine if you're capable, volunteer
what they sometimes call the crisis tent,
which is when they have redline cases, when people
are really freaking the fuck out and losing their
minds, often for hours at a time, and see how well
you handle those. If you don't handle those really
well, you should not be serving psychedelics to
anyone. So, that's my public service announcement.
Anyway, NDEs, how did you
become interested in near-death
experiences? I am deeply interested in this.
Willoughby Britton: Wow, this was not a question
that, I was like, "I wonder what part of my
website he's going to find and discover." I
totally forgot about this. I mean, I think,
wow, this is a really long time ago, but I
was really interested in temporal lobe epilepsy
and how people have religious experiences as a
result, or as part of, they call it the sacred
disease. And there's been speculation that
there've been a number of saints that had temporal
lobe epilepsy. And so, I was really interested to
know whether near-death experiencers, well, I
was just really interested in the question of
whether religious experiences and temporal
lobe epilepsy, if there was an overlap.
But, near-death experiences are actually one
of the few types of spiritual experiences
that are actually kind of similar. There's a
typography, there's a tunnel, there's a light,
there's a life review. They're kind of similar.
And so, that's kind of an ideal thing to study.
And so that's what I did. And I happen to work in
a sleep lab, and sleep is a natural activator of
hypersynchrony. So it basically, epileptiform
brain activity, because as you go to sleep,
your brain synchronizes. And so if you tend to
have epilepsy, it will show up in your sleep.
And so you can also use strobe lights, but
because people sleep and you're not really —
Tim Ferriss: Do you mean to
induce epilepsy? Do you mean?
Willoughby Britton: Yeah, it's a screener for —
Tim Ferriss: Hence,
the warnings on all the video games.
Willoughby Britton: Right, but from an
institutional review board, human subjects.
Tim Ferriss: IRB will love that.
Willoughby Britton: I'm going to induce seizures
in people, but hey, I'm not doing any induction.
They're just sleeping. I don't have to tell
them that they're — so anyway, they slept in
the lab and we looked at their brains to see
whether they had any kind of hypersynchrony,
and they did. That was the shocker.
Tim Ferriss: Wait, when you say they,
these are people with diagnosed epilepsy or
you're talking about people who had NDEs?
Willoughby Britton: I taught a class on death
and loss in graduate school. And as part of that
class, one of the people, I kind of inherited a
lot of the guest speakers from other people that
taught the class. And one of them was a woman
who had had a near-death experience, and ran a
near-death experience support group. And I was
like, "Oh, amazing." So I went, started going
to the support group, and I was like, "There's
so many of them." And then I was like, "Hey,
you guys want to come sleep in the lab, and we'll
scan your brains and see what's going on there?"
And so I kind of made friends with the
near-death support group, and that's
how that study happened. So, the group was, I
forget how many there were, but I don't know,
20 or something people who had had near-death
experiences. And then, we had people who had,
there was some type of non-near-death experience
control group. I forget if they were trauma
survivors. I can't even remember.
Tim Ferriss: A far-death experience?
Willoughby Britton: Yeah. Anyway, we had a
control group and they did not have any kind
of epileptiform activity in their brains.
Tim Ferriss: How do you explain
that? That's so fascinating.
Willoughby Britton: So I mean, I'm
pretty agnostic as to what that means.
Tim Ferriss: Just, if you're two
drinks in and speculating.
Willoughby Britton: Yeah, I mean
there's two possibilities. One is that they did
not have epileptiform activity, and it's a scar,
right? It's like a residue of the experience.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Willoughby Britton: Chances are when you have a
near-death experience, and these are people that
all had their heart stop, so they definitely had
some anoxia, oxygen deprivation, so that which can
cause hypersynchrony and epileptiform activity.
So that's one possibility. The other possibility
is that they had a sort of tendency towards
hypersynchrony, and that was what caused the
experience. But, I was very agnostic about not
choosing a position or having an interpretation.
I just said, "This group has a different, it
has a sort of distinct brain activity compared
to non-experiencers." And I just left it at that.
But what was so interesting was the response that
I got from both complete skeptics, and from
the near-death experience community. So I got
the total opposite, from no interpretation on my
part. And this has been actually a kind of thing
that's followed me for my whole life.
Tim Ferriss: The universe Rorschach
test. Let's see how people take it.
Willoughby Britton: They were like, "Thank
you so much for verifying and proving
scientifically with neuroscience," because
neuroscience can prove anything, right? "That
heaven exists." And I'm like, "Well, I don't think
I really did that, but thanks." And then these —
Tim Ferriss: I'm not sure that was in my summary.
Willoughby Britton: And then the
skeptics would write me and be like,
"Thank you for finally proving that these
people are all nuts." And I was like,
"Okay, I did neither of those things, but
that's interesting." And so, wow. I mean,
that's a whole other conversation is, be a
researcher or just talk about charged topics
and see what kind of responses you get.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, fascinating. I could
keep going on the NDEs. I have a lot of questions
about that. A lot of the descriptions seem to be
incredibly similar to the mystical experiences
reported by users of higher-dose psychedelics.
The descriptions are very, very similar,
which is interesting because you have this
sort of fear extinguishing, related to death in
both camps frequently. It seems to be the case.
And I'll ask you a question, we can cut it out of
the audio if you want, but I'm curious. So there
seemed to be, and I don't think there's anything
in any peer-reviewed studies or anything, but many
case studies of supposedly, reports of people who
observe things while their hearts are stopped or
they are technically brain-dead. So conversations
that are happening, things that are moving around,
the tools that are used. They take the dentures
out of someone and put them on a specific tray,
these types of things. Is that just complete
nonsense or do you think that's something that's
worth investigating? It's my curiosity.
Willoughby Britton: It's funny,
because I have the reputation for being the
grumpiest skeptic ever. And now I'm going to
tell you some mind-blowing stories from my
near-death experience research. What are you
trying to do to my reputation here, Tim?
Tim Ferriss: We don't have to keep it,
but I know people will be interested. And I'm
interested! I have to follow my own interests.
Willoughby Britton: I'll tell you a crazy story
that happened. This is true. And it happened. The
sort of end of the story happened recently.
I'll tell you the end of the story first.
So I was at, we want to move to Vermont,
and we're building another off-grid cabin,
so we're interviewing builders. And so we went
walking around, we met this builder, and we were
walking around this other house that he built, and
he's showing us all the features of this house.
And one of the features was a double-paned glass
that you can just flip the switch and there's an
opaque gas. Maybe you have one of those.
Tim Ferriss: No, I don't have one,
but I know the windows you're talking about.
Willoughby Britton: And I was like, "That's
so awesome." Suddenly this window goes opaque
and it's kind of foggy. And so, Matt reminded
me of this experience that this woman had in my
study. She was actually a survivor of a World War
II bombing in London. So it was a very long time
ago. First of all, she came back speaking another
language from her near-death experience.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, wow.
Willoughby Britton: So that was the first weird
thing. So I was like, all of these stories,
I was a graduate student, and all of
these stories were very far-fetched to me.
Tim Ferriss: And this was a language
she had not been exposed to?
Willoughby Britton: I don't know. But anyway, I —
Tim Ferriss: Okay, she came back
speaking another language.
Willoughby Britton: Yeah, I wasn't
paying that much attention. I was just
like, their stories were kind of, we
never published their stories, but I have them.
Tim Ferriss: You're like, "Okay, Kathy. All
right, I'll write that down."
Willoughby Britton: Yeah, I was like, "Okay, let's
see what you're — going on in your brain." But
she told me this story about, so some near-death
experiencers have, a lot of them have life
reviews, where they go through their lives and
they kind of experience the consequences of their
actions from the perspective of who they impacted,
which can be very hellish, depending on the
kind of person you've been. But then if people
are sort of dead long enough, they also have
flash forwards, where they actually not only
see the past, but also the future. So this
was one of the ones that was a flash forward.
And so she told me that she basically saw this
city and all the buildings were basically made
of this glass that had — and this is a woman,
she's probably like 80 at this time. She's not
super technologically sophisticated. And she's
describing this glass that when you flip a switch,
you can turn it. It has some kind of
gas in between it, that you can flip a
switch and it turns into opaque and that the
future will be this glass. And I was like,
"Whatever. Okay. That's so crazy sounding."
And then maybe four years later, she called
me and she was like, "The glass exists." And
she sent me to like a Scientific American or
Discover magazine, and it was like Smart
Glass, I think it's called. She's like,
"This isn't the exact company, so don't invest in
it or anything, but this is the precursor to what
it's going to be." She's like, "This is the future
of what things are going to be made out of."
Tim Ferriss: Wild.
Willoughby Britton: So again,
completely sealed off that part of my life
for, I don't know, 25 years, 23 years. And now,
I just saw the glass myself.
Tim Ferriss: In Vermont.
Willoughby Britton: So, I don't know. I don't
know. I mean, people think I'm super grumpy
and skeptical, but I'm just agnostic. I don't
know. I think just letting the mystery be there
is fine. It just doesn't need to be solved. But
I have heard crazy stories like that. I don't
know what to make of it. Will I be investing in
Smart Glass? Maybe. I mean, it can't hurt, right?
Tim Ferriss: I mean, it could hurt,
depending on how much you invest.
Willoughby Britton: Right?
Tim Ferriss: A little bit. A little bit might
go a long way, if they're going to build cities
out of it. That's amazing. Yeah, there's part
of me that with no defensible foundation, well,
I'll leave that alone for a second. But it feels
like some of these NDEs, the high dose, or they
don't even need to be high dose, but let's just
say higher dose psychedelic experiences and many
other things. Some of these meditative states are
kind of touching parts of the same thing. It's
like the five blind men holding onto different
parts of the elephant, that whole parable. But
anyway, working pet theory without a whole hell
of a lot to back it up, that would stand up to
the capital S kind of skeptic societies and so
on. But still, something that sticks in my mind.
Well, Dr. Britton, this has been great. I've
really enjoyed this conversation. I think it
will be helpful to people and to many who are
listening, probably who have had some of these
adverse events or effects, who have felt very
much alone. And certainly, I could have used
that feeling when I was going through what I
went through at my meditation retreat. Is
there anything else that you would like to
add? People can find Cheetah House on Twitter,
@cheetahhouseorg, on Facebook, cheetahhouse.org,
and Instagram, Cheetah.House. Anything that
you'd like to add before we wind to a close?
Willoughby Britton: I mean, I think that I'd like
to end just by thanking you for being as open and
forthcoming as you have been. I don't know if
you've gotten any pushback, but a number of
people who share their negative experiences, any
kind of negative experience, but particularly ones
with meditation, get a lot of kickback, and it's
not an easy thing to do. So I'm very appreciative
that you've done that and you didn't have to. I
think it's going to be really helpful for people,
and especially this kind of group of people
that emulate you and these young male,
18 to 30 demographic. In my world, you're really
a hero and doing something that's hard. And yeah,
just so, I just want to say thank you.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you. I really appreciate
you saying that. And it's my pleasure to do it
because by offering my story, I'm not saying,
"Meditation bad." I actually find meditation in
small doses to be incredibly, incredibly helpful
in my life. And that is not mutually exclusive
with also saying, "Hey, in different formats and
different doses, things can go off the rails."
And you need to, being a good boy or girl scout,
be prepared for that. And institutions and groups,
and facilitators and centers need to be prepared
for that. And hope is not a strategy, right?
It's like you get in your car and drive with the
seatbelt off. It's like, that's just stupid. It's
like maybe you haven't had a head-on collision,
but they happen every day, so wear a
seatbelt. I mean, they're basic precautions.
And I hope that will help people to think about
this in a sort of risk-informed way, not so that
they can say, "I'm never going to meditate,"
but simply to know this is a possibility and to
ensure that they have support structures around
to help them, in case they run into turbulence
or something even more extreme, as I did. And
that's true for so many things in life, and I
really appreciate you doing the research you do.
I'm sure you get a hell of a lot of flack for it.
And, it's important to have this be part of the
conversation, and it's going to increasingly
be part of the conversation. I mean, you have
startups and companies that are worth billions
of dollars promoting mindfulness and meditation.
You have the same thing happening in psychedelics,
lots of profit motives, which is not automatically
something that begets evil, but it does beget
incentives. And that means, we will most certainly
have tens of thousands, potentially hundreds of
thousands and millions of people engaging with
things, that historically were pretty limited to
a fine slice of the population. And, we are going
to see adverse events. You know what? I promise,
one other thing that I have to ask about.
So how did the Dalai Lama receive your
description of your research?
Willoughby Britton: Oh,
boy. Did you watch the video?
Tim Ferriss: No, I didn't see the video. I saw
some text about it, but I did not see the video.
Willoughby Britton: Okay. So there is a video of
me presenting to the Dalai Lama, as part of
the Mind & Life Dialogues. I will let viewers
make their own decisions about what they think.
I will tell you some feedback that I got. I mean,
you'll see me there, if you want to watch
Willoughby in sympathetic overload. It was
a pretty terrifying experience in general. So,
I don't really remember the feedback as it was
happening, because I was a little bit out
of my body probably, but there were a lot
of people there. The entire Mind & Life Board
was there. And so, they gave me some feedback.
A lot of people found his response fairly
dismissive and also, a bit not particularly
compassionate. He was laughing half the time.
And I was like, "Well, did I tell you that
the duration of impairment was three years?"
Also, the people that it happened to were some
of our best and brightest meditation teachers.
Name any meditation teacher that you can name,
who's written Dharma books. He was probably in
our study and he probably had a meditation-related
challenge. And the Dalai Lama was basically
saying, that this happened to people because
they didn't have enough Buddhist training. And
it was like, I don't know. So, I don't know.
You're not really supposed to talk shit about the
Dalai Lama, so you might want to cut this one out.
Tim Ferriss: People need to grow up, come on.
Willoughby Britton: But I wasn't particularly
impressed, if you're allowed to say that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Willoughby Britton: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: It's fine. I just think people need
to grow up. It's like if you have externalized
your agency into someone you view as a god,
you're setting yourself up for trouble. And I
think, I am not a Dalai Lama expert. I'm sure that
he has, and demonstrably, has offered a lot to the
world, but it doesn't mean he's infallible. Right?
Willoughby Britton: Well, and this is also, my
husband was like, "He's the Dalai Lama. He was
brought up from age zero until however old
he is now, to defend Buddhism. What do you
expect?" So I think that's a pretty good answer.
And also, it's very emblematic of, it's possible
that certain teachers have never heard of any
problems, because why would you tell them that?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
Willoughby Britton: You never
want to be the one that's failing the practice
that they're giving you, or telling them that
the practice that they gave you is harming you.
That's just not even a possibility. So yeah,
it is what it is. Yeah, I left it up there as
sort of a historical marker, but I didn't refer
you to it, because it's kind of a mixed bag.
Tim Ferriss: All right, so boys and girls
out there, be safe. Measure twice,
cut once. And thank you, Willoughby,
so much for the time. I really have enjoyed this.
I think it will be valuable for people, and at the
very least it's going to spark conversation.
So I'm going to get a ton of shit. I'm fine
with it, because I think this is important.
And for people listening, you'll find links
to everything, the resources we've mentioned, any
books, et cetera, people, and so on, in the show
notes as per usual at Tim.blog/podcast. And until
next time, be a little kinder than is necessary,
not just to others, but to yourself. I'll quote
Jack Kornfield actually, which, and I'm going to
paraphrase here, but if your compassion does not
include yourself, then it is incomplete. And part
of being compassionate now, this is my voice, is
making sure you account for risks. And not live
in fear, but certainly live informed. So until
next time, everyone, thank you for tuning in.